all right for now the conflict in
eastern europe is contained to two
nations russia and ukraine but what
happens if this spills over and becomes
a global war don't think it's
far-fetched joining us now neil ferguson
thinks about this a lot a hoover
institute senior fellow writes great
stuff about conflicts like this how this
could spiral out of control neil is that
a legitimate worry
well i think vladimir putin wants us to
think that it is because it's part of
his strategy of intimidating the west
threatening nuclear weapons or chemical
weapons most recently today saying that
they will attack transports of weapons
coming from poland to ukraine
and unfortunately the response of the
west is uh to go weak at the knees and
say no no no uh we don't want at any uh
price to fight russia because that would
be world war iii uh president biden
tweeted that just today
signaling to putin that we're desperate
to avoid escalation and this of course
emboldens him to carry on his war of of
of murder and destruction
in ukraine
so if we're rational actors he looks at
his weakness
but yet you want to be national because
if you're the person that could make a
decision that would result in blowing up
the world that's that's a lot to think
about for example as we look at europe
you have russia if they were to go after
one of the article 5 of one of the nato
nations article 5's enacted let's say
they go after poland and follow some
truck into poland and they blow it up
article 5 goes so incomes all of nato
nato slovakia i'll just enact this
so in comes the czech republic hungary
all these nations uh are all in right
ukraine they're all fighting russia all
they have is belarus and that would be a
reluctant ally correct
that's right nato is a very large
alliance there's 30 members of which the
united states is the most important and
it has a very clear commitment uh an
attack on one is an attack on all that's
article 5. which is why i think putin is
bluffing i do not think that uh he's
going to attack poland he's struggling
to win this war against an isolated
ukraine which is not a member of nato
remember brian part of the reason this
war is happening is that we said back in
2008 that the ukraine could join nato
and then we never followed through in
fact we kept saying roughly like this
you know you can join but how about
never uh would never suit you and and
that is of course why the war began
because putin was not deterred there was
no article 5 protection i think he's
bluffing brian i think he was bluffing
when he talked about nuclear weapons i
think he's bluffing when he talks about
chemical weapons and i'm absolutely sure
he's bluffing if he implies that he
could attack
a nato country such as poland he would
have the entirety
of the rest of europe against him and of
course
the united states so i think this is a
bluff and we keep falling for it
consistently brian the biden
administration has shown weakness all of
last year they took sanctions off
nordstrom 2 the pipeline to bypass
ukraine uh they slowed down weapon
deliveries which they should have in
fact been stepping up and they pledged
not to get involved in fighting russia
if there were an invasion these signals
of weakness are the reason that putin
went ahead with his invasion confident
that he would not have to fight anybody
other than ukraine i mean all he would
have he'd have china people say well
china jump in that's you know that's up
for debate would he have against him is
taiwan if you look at this region japan
south korea of course north korea would
come in on their side as we look around
the world if you want a true world war
you look at the middle east okay they
would have syria
turkey they're not supposed to but who
knows and then you they'd have yemen
perhaps and maybe pakistan but how many
people want to blow up their country for
russia that's the question and in south
korea and when you look at south america
they'd have venezuela good luck with
that so i think we should start acting
like a super power who has a superior
military and superior nuclear weapons
final thought neil how does this play
out i want to talk to you in six weeks
what is what is the result of this
i'm very sorry to say that i fear
ukrainian resistance will ultimately be
crushed by the sheer might of russian
bombardment putin is going to grind out
further advances he still has a chance
of encircling and taking kiev and i'm
very much afraid that unless the biden
administration changes its strategy
and stands up to putin and tries to
bring an end to this war it is going to
end in a hideous uh and brutal victory
by russia which will leave putin intact
and our strategy will have failed
completely that is what i fear we'll be
discussing maybe in less than six weeks
yeah i wish you weren't right so often
with that result but uh sadly i think
you are neil ferguson thanks so much
appreciate it
one thing we can all agree on uh we want
to donate to ukraine relief they need
your help so visit redcross.com.org
fox forward hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now